اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين وهنا جلسات
والى رمز
بجوله ثانيه وحمله مليئه بالوعود بدء سباق
الرئاسه التركيه اقبال لافت واجراءات
امنيه مشدده
[موسيقى]
بعد الهجمات الروسيه المكثفه كيف تدعو
سكانها للبقاء في الملاجئ وموسكو تستنفر
على الحدود
هدنه السودان تترنح بين خروق مستمره رفعت
حصيله الضحايا وبين تحضيرات امميه من
تفاقم الازمه الانسانيه
اتصال الفرصه الاخيره ينقذ امريكا من تعثر
غير مسبوق بايدن ومكارتي يتوصلان للاتفاق
مبدئي حول سقف الدين
صباح الخير واهلا بكم بجوله ثانيه وحملات
مليئه بالوعود تعيش تركيا مشاهدينا يوما
حاسما يكتمل فيه نصاب المشهد الانتخابي
لمن سيقود البلاد فقد انطلقت الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئيسيه صباحا
واستقبلت مراكز الاقتراع الناخبين في احدى
وثمانين محافظه وذلك في نحو 192 الف صندوق
اختراع وعززت الدوله لاجراءات الامنيه في
اكبر مدن تركيا ونشرت مئات الالاف من
افراد الشرطه حتى يتمكن الناخبون من
ممارسه حقهم في التصويت بامان وتحتدم
المنافسه بين الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
وخصمه زعيم المعارضه
بعد تحقيق اردوغان تقدما مريحا بنحو خمسه
نقاط على منافسه كمال كريش دار اوغلو في
الجوله الاولى مع حصوله على تاييد نسبه
49.52% بينما حصل نظيره كري شدار على
44.88
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان صويلو ان
العمليه الانتخابيه تجري من دون اي مشاكل
في عموم محافظات تركيا والبالغه 81 واضاف
عقب ادلائه بصوته في الانتخابات انه تم
نشر اكثر من 600 الف فرد لتامين العمليه
الانتخابيه وعدم تسجيل اي مخالفات حتى
الان وتوقع اصدار النتائج في وقت ابكر من
الجوله الاولى كما شدد على ان قوات الامن
على اهبه الاستعداد لحمايه صناديق
الاقتراع اما من جانبه اكد رئيس هيئه
الانتخابات التركيه احمد ان هناك اقبالا
كبيرا على مراكز الاقتراع من قبل الناخبين
في جوله الاعاده الحاسمه وقال في اول
افاده صحفيه ان العمليه الانتخابيه تسير
من دون مشاكل وان هناك اتجاها لرفع الحظر
الاعلامي عن نشر نتائج الانتخابات الذي
يستمر ثلاث ساعات عبر غلق صناديق الاقتراع
في وقت مبكر مقارنه بالجوله الاولى
معنى من اسطنبول مفيده العربيه راويه
القاسم ومن انقره مراسل العربيه زيدان
زنكلو واهلا بكم اعزائي ابدا معك راويه من
اسطنبول كيف تبدو الصوره وكيف هو الاقبال
حتى اللحظه على التصويت وكيف هي الاجواء
بشكل عام هل هناك حماس هل هناك تخوف
اهلا بك فاطمه وبزيدان و بالمشاهدين يعني
هناك اقبال كبير في هذا المركز الذي انا
اتواجد فيه حيث ننتظر وصول الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان ونشاهد الناس تتجمهر هناك لالقاء
التحيه عندما يصل على الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان طبعا
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات ورئيسها احمد
ينار تحدث عن الاقبال الشديد بجوله
الاعاده وبانها تسير بدون مشاكل خاصه هناك
نشر لاكثر من 600 الف عنصر امني وطائرات
ومسيرات لتامين العمليه الانتخابيه رئيسه
الحزب الجيد ميرال اكشينار
لا بصوتها قالت بان هذه انتخابات مهمه
لمستقبل البلاد وخاصه للشباب هنالك ايضا
نقطه مهمه وزاره الداخليه اتخذت تدابير
نعم فاطمه بدايه تحيا لك ولراويه في
اسطنبول طبعا الاقبال كبير جدا في هذا
المركز الذي نتواجد فيه هنا في وسط
العاصمه التركيه انقره منطقه شانكايا حيث
سيدلي بعد قليل زعيم المعارضه والمرشح
الرئاسي كمال كلجد دارولو بصوته في هذه في
هذا المركز طبعا منذ ساعات الصباح نحن
نتواجد في هذا المركز
ازدحام كبير في غرف هذه المدرسه التي تضم
صناديق الاقتراع فيها حوالي سبعه الاف
ناخب مسجل بعد نصف ساعه فقط من بدء
التصويت في تمام الساعه الثامنه والنصف
سالنا مدير المركز عن نسبه الاقبال قال ان
10% من الناخبين الذين يحق لهم التصويت في
هذا المركز قد صوتوا في نصف ساعه الاولى
وهذا يدلل على اقبال كبير جدا هنا في هذه
المنطقه التي نتواجد فيها وكما صرح احمد
ينار قبل قليل وادلى بصوته هنا ايضا في
هذا المركز وكما ذكرتم انت ورا ويه ان
نسبه الاقبال ونقلا هنا عن احمد ينار
كبيره وايضا ذكر نقطه اخرى ان رفع الحظر
المفروض عن نشر النتائج سيكون من المتوقع
ان يكون ابكر نظرا لان الانتخابات هي
انتخابات رئاسيه وكما اكد ايضا وزير
الداخليه سليمان سولو بان ربما
عمليه فرز الاصوات تتم بشكل اسرع لان
الانتخابات فقط رئاسيه بالنسبه الى انقره
عدد الناخبين الذين يحق لهم التصويت اربع
ملايين او يتجاوز اربع ملايين ومئتين الف
ناخب في اكثر من 12 اكثر من 12.200 مركز
اختراع يصوتون بالنسبه للجوله الاولى نسبه
المشاركه في انقره تجاوزت 91% اعطى حاجه
منها
47.3 بينما الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان حاز
على 46% من اصوات سكان العاصمه طيب اعود
اليك راويه يعني كنت تودين ان تنقلي الينا
ما رصدتي ايضا من خلال مشاهداتك في
اسطنبول تفضلي
النتائج تواليا يلتقل على فاطمه كنت اود
الاشاره الى انه الطقس
الماطر هنا في اسطنبول لم يمنع الناس من
المشاركه بكثافه وحتى الذين لديهم يعني
حاجات خاصه هناك نظام هنا في تركيا مثل
كركاله ولايه كركالي مثلا وغيرها من
الولايات الاشخاص الذين لديهم حاجات خاصه
صناديق الاقتراع تذهب الى بيوتهم ويمكنهم
الادلاء بصوتهم من هناك طبعا نحن هنا في
جوله الاعاده لانه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
لم يقدر نذكر بان يحصل على الخمسين زائد
واحد
ومثل ما ذكر زيدان عمليه الفرس ستكون اسرع
لانه هنا يعني سيتم اختيار رئيس للدوله
فقط وليس الانتخابات البرلمانيه ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لكما من اسطنبول مفيدات
العربيه راويه القاسم ومن انقره مراسل
العربيه زيدان زنكلو
في اللحظات الاخيره قبل السباق وجه
المرشحان رساله قبل جوله الاعاده فماذا
قال كل منهما اردوغان حث الاتراك على
المشاركه باعداد كبيره في عمليه التصويت
داعيا كل من لم يتمكن من الذهاب الى
التصويت في الجوله الاولى للمشاركه في
الثانيه بينما دعى منافسه كليجدار اوغلو
دعنا الى انتشار بلادهم مما وصفها بالحفره
المظلمه التي احاطت بالبلاد خلال حكم
اردوغان الممتد منذ عقدين على حد قوله ومن
اسطنبول ينضم الينا فائق بولوت المحلل
السياسي اهلا بك معنا سيد فائق اذا ما ان
تحدثنا عن اردوغان او كريشدار ما هو
المستقبل السياسي المتوقع لكل منهما ماء
خسر يعني ان خسرت ليشتار هل انتهى مستقبله
السياسي وكذلك اردوغان
يعني
ممكن قول انا اذا
فقد او خسر السيد رجب طيب اردوغان لا
اعتقد انه مستقبله السياسي ان ينتهي لانه
هو سوف
يستعاده ويبرمج او يخطط ان يكون مثلا رئيس
يعني في البرلمان التركي طبعا رئيس
المعارضه في البرلمان وبحث سوف يقود خلينا
نقول سياسه
شديده اللهجه يعني
وسياسه ممكن تواتر طبعا
لحرب في حرب الكلاميه لاستنزاف يعني
المعارضه او فايز سيد كل من يشتروا حساب
المتحالفه تحت
الائتلاف الامه بالنسبه
خسره فانا بعتقد انه لا اعتقد يعني سوف
تنتهي للحياه السياسيه ولكن سوف يعني هناك
تحدث مشاكل مختلفه للصوان داخل الحزب سواء
سواء في تحالف الامه فهذا يعني بالنسبه
تشير بانه ما ان خسرك ليشدار في هذه
الجوله الثانيه فانها فانه يوقع على
اعدامه السياسي لانه لم يكن المرشح
المرغوب به حقيقه من قبل الطاوله السداسيه
ولكن اسمح لنا ان نتوقف مع اخر نتائج
استطلاعات للراي في تركيا حيث تشير او
تشير اغلبها الى ان الفجوه بين الرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان وزعيم المعارضه
كمان كريجدار اوغلو في الانتخابات
الرئيسيه التركيه ستكون 5% على الاقل طبعا
اي مشابهه لما كانت عليه النتيجه في
الجوله الاولى واظهر استطلاع اجراه مركز
او زيدنبير او اوزنبير ان نحو 54% من
اصوات الناخبين مستعدون لدعم اردوغان
بينما سيدعم اكثر من
46%جدار اوغلو واظهر استطلاع راي اجراه
مركز دراسه الراي العام ايزيم انا اردوغان
سيحصل على نحو 54% من الاصوات بينما سيحصل
على
46% اعود الى من اسطنبول فائق بولوت
المحلل السياسي سيد فائق يعني استطلاعات
راي مختلفه وعده استطلاعات رايهم البعض
منها يشير الى ان اردوغان سيفوز يعني فارق
مريح جدا ما توقعاتك انت في هذه الجوله
الثانيه التي تشابه بشكل كبير الجوله
الاولى
يا سيدتي يعني انا بعتقد ان نحيا بعناويه
نحيا نفسيه يعني بما ان السيد رجب
تايبردون هو فائز الاول في الجوله الاولى
فطبعا من الناحيه النفسيه يعني ممكن
تشير الى معنويات قويه جدا لدى مسوتين كل
من السيد رجب تايبردوغان ايضا ولكن هناك
ثمان استعاره اخرى تنافي استدعات التي
قدمته قدمت قدمت انت فهي تشير ايضا الى
فوز السيد كمال ولا انها استطلاعات الممكن
ان نقول قليله جدا
ممكن يعني انا اقول يعني
في السياسه دائما
دائما في مجال لمعجزات لان في عاده في
تركيا جماهير
جماهير تركيا تميل الى
تصويت لصالح الفائز الاول ولكن في امر اخر
ايضا حقيقه فهي من التجربه التركيه على ان
خلال اعاده الجوله او يعني خلال
الانتخابات اخر
المسوتين يغيرون موقفهم وبالتالي يصوتنا
له هذا مثلا اذا صوت السيد سيد رجب طيب
اردوغان في هذه المره يصوت لصالح لصالح
مثلا كما يشتروا او بالعكس
فلذلك انا بعتقد حتى ارقام ايضا تشير الى
يعني اذا جاهد بدل جهودا جباره يعني
ثمن
[موسيقى]
السيد كمال كريست يعني سوف يحقق معجزه
لانه في مجال في معجزات هذه المعجزات في
السياسه العامه
من جهه من جهه اخرى نعرف انه في فتره
الاخيره حسب التحالف الامه غير تكتيكو
فبحيث يعني
ركز عرب مسائل التي كانت
تتهم تتهم بها
من قبل طبعا
تحالف الجمهوري ولذلك مثلا
ركز على الوطنيه على قوميه مركزه على يعني
طبعا ناخبين اخرين الذين طبعا امتنعوا عن
تصفيه لاننا
كما هي التوقعات متفاوته ويبقى النتائج
النهائيه للانتخابات هي المفصل وسننتظر
حتى ذلك الحين شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول
فائق بولوت المحلل السياسي
يجمع الاتراك مشاهدينا على ان فئه الشباب
هي كلمه سر الفوز في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التي تجري نظرا لضخامه عددهم حيث ان معظم
جيل الشباب التركي ولد بعد وصول حزب
العداله والتنميه في عام 2022 الى السلطه
كيف ركزت الحملات الانتخابيه على الشباب
نتابع
تتجه الانظار في جوله الاعاده الانتخاب
رئيس لتركيا الى جيل الشباب او كما يقال
له جيل زين هؤلاء معروف بانهم يصوتون
ويريدون ان يصوتوا لكم نحن الان في بشكتاش
ميدان التي تعتبر معقل المعارضه التركيه
الشباب الذين التقيناهم هنا يقولون نريد
التغيير بعضهم ممن عمره 20 عاما لم يعرف
سوى حكومه اردوغان والحكومات التي كان هو
رئيس للجمهوريه فيها بعضهم ليس يعني لديه
رئيس سلبي باردوغان ولكن بكل بساطه يريد
التغيير يريد المزيد من الحريه وايضا
الديمقراطيه
من ستنتخب ولماذا
ساصوت لصالحك لانني اجد افكاري متعلقه
بالحقوق والعداله تتناسب مع كل جدار اوغلو
ارى ايضا ان هناك استقطابا شديدا داخل
البلاد ونستطيع تحمل هذا الوضع
ما الخطاب العنصري واخراج اصرار المعارض
على اخراج اللاجئين السوريين فورا هل انت
مع ذلك
قال سبيل المثال يوجد اتراكم في المانيا
وربما يوجد سوريون في تركيا لكنهم يجب ان
يكونوا تحت الرقابه اذ لم تبسط السيطره
تنكسر الديمقراطيه ويكون هناك سوريون اكثر
من الاتراك سيكون هناك تعقيدات لان هؤلاء
اناس من ثقافات مختلفه هناك اناس لديهم
ثقافات مختلفه في بلدان مختلفه لكنها ليست
مشكله لانهم يفعلون ذلك بطريقه منتظمه
يمكن للسوريين والافغان والباكستانيين
الاذكياء الذين يساعدون بلدنا البقاء في
بلدنا لكنني اؤيد ترحيل الباقين لمن ستصوت
اليوم
كعادتي سادعم رئيسنا رجب طيب
اردوغانجا لم اصوت لحزب الشعبي الجمهوري
من قبل لكن من اجل مستقبل بلدنا من اجل
مستقبل شبابنا سادعم الشعب الجمهوري لياتي
السلام للبلاد لتاتي الاخوه لهذا السبب
ساصوت لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
لماذا ستصوت لرجب طيب اردوغان
ادعم رئيسنا رجب طيب اردوغان على خدماته
واعماله التي يراها الجميع
متى بدا الاتراك بانتخاب الرئيس بشكل
مباشر وكيف كانت عمليه انتخاب الرئيس من
قبل نتابع التفاصيل مع زيدان زنكلو من
انقره
للمره الثالثه يختار الاتراك رئيسهم
بواسطه الاقتراع المباشر قبل ذلك كان يتم
انتخاب الرئيس بواسطه البرلمان بعد
انتخابات برلمانيه لكن في عام 2007 وبعد
ازمه رافقت انتخاب الرئيس السابق عبد الله
جولف جرى تعديل دستوري تم بموجبه الموافقه
على انتخاب الرئيس بشكل مباشر من قبل
الشعب في عام 2014 جرت اولى الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في البلاد وفاز فيها الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان بنسبه تجاوزت 51% وكان حينها
منافسه الرئيسي اكمل الدين احسان اوغلو
الامين العام الاسبق لمنظمه التعاون
الاسلامي في عام 2018 جرت انتخابات مبكره
وفاز فيها ايضا الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
بنسبه تجاوزت 52% وكان حينها منافسه
الابرز محرم انجا مرشح حزب الشعب الجمهوري
في انتخابات الرابعه عشر من مايو حصل
الرئيس اردوغان ما نسبته
49.5% من اصوات الناخبين وحصل منافسه
الرئيسي كمال كلجدار اوغلو على ما نسبته
44.8
ولان ايا من المرشحين لم يحصل على خمسين
زائد واحد وهي النسبه المطلوبه للفوز
بمنصب الرئيس جرت جوله اعاده هذه الجوله
هي الاولى من نوعها في تاريخ تركيا وهي
التي ستحدد الرئيس الثالث عشر للجمهوريه
التركيه من العاصمه التركيه انقره لقناتي
العربيه والحدث زيدان زنجلو
[موسيقى]
نتحدث بعض الفاصل عن
اعلان زيلينس عقوبات او سعد الضروسيا تضم
شركات اسلحه متورطه في الحرب
احييكم من جديد في عيد تاسيس العاصمه
الاوكرانيه امطرت روسيا كييف بالغارات
الصاروخيه او باستخدام الطائرات المسيره
هجوم قالت سلطات كييف انه الاكبر منذ
بدايه الحرب وعلى وقع صافرات الانذار جراء
هجمات مسيرات طلبت السلطات الاوكرانيه من
سكان العاصمه البقاءة في الملاجئ فيما
اعلنت اسقاط اثنتين وخمسين طائره مسيره من
اصل 54 مسيره اطلقتها روسيا الليله
الماضيه كما اعلن عمدات بلديه كييف عن
تدمير مستودع في حي غولوفيزيسكي نتيجه
حريق اثراء سلسله الانفجارات الاخيره
[موسيقى]
معنا الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا بك معنا
محمد اذا بعد الهجمات المكثفه والعنيفه
على العاصمه والتي وصفت بانها الاكثر عنفا
منذ بدايه الحرب وبعد مطالبه المواطنين
بالبقاء في الملاجئ كيف هي الصوره الان في
ضواحي العاصمه
العاصمه الاوكرانيه غياب شهدت ليلى تعتبر
الاعنف منذ فتره طويله منذ بدايه الحرب
الروسيه والغزل الروسي للاراضي الاوكرانيه
عندها 12:30 دوره سفارات الانذار في معظم
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بعد معلومات عن اطلاق
روسيا لمسير سيارات من نوع الشاهد 136
باتجاه عدد من المدن الاوكرانيه يعني حصه
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف كانت الاكبر اكثر
من 41 مسيره اطلقت على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
بينها مسيره واحده سقطت على احد
المستودعات مما ادى الى حريق على مساحه
1000 متر مربع الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
منذ الساعه الواحده والنصف حتى الساعه
السادسه صباحا او الخامسه ونصف كانت تقوم
باسقاط هذه المسيرات التي يعني اصوات
الانفجارات كانت تسمع بشكل كبير على طول
عرض العاصمه الاوكرانيه هي من الجهه
الشماليه من الجهه الجنوبيه بحسب وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه تم اسقاط عدد من
المسيرات في مناطق في مناطق في مناطق حيث
ادى يعني هذه المسيرات الى اضرار في
المباني وبالسيارات وشب حريق في منطقه
هالاساسكي بعد سقوط مسيره على احد المنازل
وبحسب يعني الحصيله النهائيه هناك قتيل
وثلاثه جرحى بفعل سقوط بقايا المسيره اما
في مقاطعه احدى المسيرات اصابت هدف وهي
منشاه بنى تحتيها محطه لوصل شبكات الطياره
الكهربائي بين التوتر العالي والشبكه
العاديه مما ادى الى انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي عند بعض المدن تعمل فرق الصيانه
على يعني اعاده تشغيل التيار الكهربائي في
تلك المنطقه تشرينيج واسومي ايضا كان لهم
حصه في اسقاط المسيرات لان هذه الهجمه
يعني بالمسيرات ايرانيه تصنع تعتبر الاضخم
للمره الاولى يتم اطلاق 54 مسيره في يعني
على دفعتين باتجاه المدن الام
يعني ارباك الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
حتى تستطيع وايضا يعني
هجوم الروسي سريعا محمد اود ان اسالك عن
هل من بوادر يعني قرب الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد لاننا نرى على السوشيال ميديا كثير
من الفيديوهات لقائد الجيش الاوكراني ربما
وفيديوهات اخرى هل هي دلاله على قرب هذا
الهجوم المضاد
يعني هناك بعض الضباط والمسؤولين في وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه والجيش الاوكراني وحتى
الاداره الرئاسيه بداوا يتحدثوا عن
المرحله الاولى للهجوم المضاد ولن يكون
الذي لن يكون كهجوم كلاسيكي فقط تقدم او
محاولات اقتحام من القوات الاوكرانيه بل
تبدا بقطع الشرايين التي تمد او خطوط
الامداد التي تعتبر الشرايين لمد يعني
القوات الروسيه التي تقاتل عند الجبهات
بالعتاد والسلاح لذلك الجيش الاوكراني
يقوم منذ يومين حتى الان اكثر من 41 مخزن
ومركز قياده للقوات الروسيه تم تدبيرها في
عمق الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
بالامس كان هناك هجوم على برياس على
ماريوبول على لوغانست مدينه وعلى مدينه
لذلك الجيش الاوكراني المرحله الاولى من
الهجوم المضاد هو الاعداد للهجوم البري
عبر تدمير يعني الامدادات اللوجستيه وذلك
لاضعاف القوات التي القوات الروسيه التي
تكون بالدفاع في الخطوط الاولى واضحه
الصوره شكرا جزيلا لك محمد البابا
اعلنا مقر الطوارئ في اقليم كرسوندار في
روسيا ان مسيرات عده حاولت الاقتراب من
اراضي مصفاه السكي واشار الى انه تم تحييد
هذه المسيرات من دون اضرار وكانت مصفاه
السكي تعرضت في مطلع مايو لهجمات بمسيارات
وقد نجم عنها حرائق استمرت الى يومين
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلنسكي اعلن
عن عقوبات اكثر صرامه ضد روسيا لانهاء
حربها على اوكرانيا وقال الرئيس الاوكراني
220 شركه وواحد وخمسين شخصا تمت اضافتهم
الى قائمه العقوبات واشار الى ان معظم من
تضمنتهم القائمه الاضافيه شركات اسلحه
مرتبطه بشركات روسيه تخدم الحرب في
المقابل امر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بتعزيز الامن على الحدود الروسيه بضمان اي
تحرك عسكري ومدني روسيا سريع الى المناطق
الاوكرانيه الخاضعه الان لسيطره موسكو وفي
خطوه لاحقت فيها بالمجر منعت اليونان
تطبيق الحزمه الحاديه عشر من عقوبات
الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد روسيا وذلك وفق ما
ذكرت صحيفه بوليتكو الامريكيه ونقلا عن
مصادر دبلوماسيه في بروكسيل فان هذه
الحزمه مشاهدينا تتضمن فرد قيود على
الشركات من دول ثالثه لا تتجاوب مع
اجراءات الحظر الذي يفرضها الاتحاد واكدت
المصادر ان كلتا الدولتين تطالبان كييز
بازاله شركتهما من قائمه العقوبات
الاوكرانيه بزعم ان هذه الشركات تدعم
روسيا
نتحدث بعد الفاصل عن
الذكاء الاصطناعي وخطواته السريعه تخيف
سوق العمل البريطاني
رمز
بجوله ثانيه وحمله مليئه بالوعود بدء سباق
الرئاسه التركيه اقبال لافت واجراءات
امنيه مشدده
بعد الهجمات الروسيه المكثفه كيف تدعو
سكانها للبقاء في الملاجئ وموسكو تستنفر
على الحدود
هدنه السودان تترنح بين خروج مستمره رفعت
حصيله الضحايا وتحذيرات امميه من تفاقم
الازمه الانسانيه
واتصال الفرصه الاخيره ينقذ امريكا من
تعثر غير مسبوق بايدن يتوصلان لاتفاق
مبدئي حول سقف الدين
اهلا بكم من جديد نذكر باليوم الحاسم في
تركيا حيث يواصل النخبون الادلاء باصواتهم
في الجوله الثانيه من انتخابات الرئاسيه
اقبال كبير على صناديق الاقتراع بحسب ما
اكد رئيس هيئه الانتخابات التركيه اما
وزير الداخليه التركيه سليمان سويلو قال
ان العمليه الانتخابيه تجري من دون اي
مشاكل في عموم محافظات تركيا مشيرا الى
انه تم نشر اكثر من 600 الف فرد تامين
العمليه الانتخابيه وعدم تسجيل اي خروج
شاهدينا صور مباشره من احد مراكز الاقتراع
في العاصمه او في اسطنبول مراكز اقتراع
مكتظه بالصحفيين واقبال كبير من الناخبين
يعني يتوجهون الى مراكز الاقتراع اليوم في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
[موسيقى]
من تركيا الى السودان اعلنت نقابه الاطباء
ارتفاع عدد الوفيات من المدنيين جراء
الصراع الى 866 فيما تم تسجيل 3000
وسبعمائه
اصابه من جهه اخرى قال وزير الصحه
السوداني هيثم محمد ان ثلاث ولايات
سودانيه هي الخرطوم جنوب ووسط دارفور
تعاني من ازمه في الخدمات الصحيه واشار
الى ان 30 مستشفى في ولايه الخرطوم تعجزوا
عن تقديم الخدمات نتيجه وجود قوات الدعم
السريع داخلها بالاضافه الى عدد من
المستشفيات المركزيه كذلك في الاثناء
افادت وكالات الاغاثه ان المواطنين
الباقين في الخرطوم يعانون من انهيار
الخدمات مثل الكهرباء والمياه وشبكات
الاتصالات وبحسب ما ذكرت وكالات اغاثه
لوكاله رويترز ما زال من الصعب الحصول على
الموافقات الحكوميه والضمانات الامنيه
لنقل المساعدات والموظفين الموجودين في
مناطق اكثر امنا البلاد الى الخرطوم
وغيرها من المناطق المضطربه على الرغم من
الهدنه هذا وبين برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
التابعه للامم المتحده بين على تويتر انه
كان قد بدا في تقديم مساعدات غذائيه لمن
هم في الخرطوم لكن يلزم توفير السلامه
والامن وامكانيه الدخول الى المناطق
لزياده الدعم الى 500 الف شخص هذا ودع
رئيس المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين دعا الى وقف فوري لاطلاق
النار بين طرفي الصراع الدائري في السودان
وذلك لتهيئه الظروف الملائمه لوصول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى المناطق المتضرره
من النزاع وقال فليبيون جراندي ان وكاله
الاغاثه الانسانيه مستعده لتقديم المساعده
للشعب السوداني لكن الحل الحقيقي يكمن في
ايدي طرفي الصراع كما حث الجانبين على
محاوله التخفيف من الكارثه الانسانيه
الناجمه عن هذا الصراع
ولرصد الوضع في اقليم دارفور الذي شهد
بالامس معارك عنيفه من هناك ينضم الينا
عبر الهاتف الصحفي صالح ابو علامه اهلا بك
معنا السيد صالح اذا وضع يعني متوتر في
الاقليم شهد بالامس معارك عنيفه اشتباكات
عنيفه كيف هي الصوره الان حيث انت
اهلا بك زميلنا فاطمه ومرحبا بجميع متابعي
قناه العربيه الوضع في اقليم دارفور ما
زال سخن جدا في عاصمه مدينه الفاشر
الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع تدخل
في اليوم الرابع حتى هذا الصباح هنالك
اصوات للقذائف تسمع وتبادل لاطلاق النار
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في مدينه الفاشر
حتى الان النزوح مستمر في الاحياء
الجنوبيه الشرقيه الى الاحياء الامنه في
مدينه الفاشر كما ان عمليات النهب والسلب
ايضا والتعدي على ايضا مستمر داخل المدينه
لم ترد الينا حتى الان ارقام بالوفيات
والاصابات في صفوف المدنيين نسبه للتوتر
الكبير للوضع وعدم الدخول لهذه الاحياء
حتى هذه اللحظه هنالك مساعي كبيره لاحتواء
هذا الصراع الذي نشب بعد مبادرات عديده في
المدينه تم فيها الزام طرفات صراع بعدم
القتال لكن القتال تجدد مره اخرى هذه
المره هو بصوره عنيفه في مدينه الفاشر
حاكم غلندارفور يعني قبل تجدد الصراع تحدث
بان على الجميع المحافظه على اقليم دارفور
امن نسبه لهشاشه الاقليم ونزوه للموقع
الذي يتمتع به اقليم دارفور ولكن تجددت
القتال مره اخرى
بالفاشر والمتاعيه الان تجري المبادرات
وغيرها لاحتواء القتال هناك في شمال
دارفور اما في مدينه نيالا بجنوب دارفور
وضع الصحي ما زالت كارثي في المدينه عدد
من المستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه
مبادرات للاطباء الان تجري لاعاده العمل
في المستشفى التخصصي والمستشفى التعليمي
بينيالا وفي السابق يعني هذه المستشفيات
كانت تقع في مرمى النيران داخل المدينه
وسط المدينه هنالك ايضا مركز مركز الكلى
ايضا تاثر كثيرا خلال الاشتباكات الماضيه
المبادرات تسعى لاعاده الوضع الصحي
المتردد جدا في نيالا هنالك
نعم لضيق الوقت اشكرك جزيل الشكر من اقليم
دار فور
الصحفي صالح ابو علمه
الى فلسطين وتحديدا الضفه الغربيه والتي
اعتقل فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي خمسه
فلسطينيين خلال عمليه اقتحام متزامنه في
طولكرم والخليل في الضفه الغربيه وقالت
مصادر طبيه في طولكرم ان شابا اصيب بجراح
متوسطه جراء عيار مطاطي اصابه في الراس
بعدما ادت عمليات الاقتحام الاسرائيليه
الى وقوع اشتباكات
حل وسطي وخطوه ستحول دونما او تحول دون ما
تعثر كورسي في امريكا هكذا اشاد الرئيس جو
بايدن بوضع الخطوط العريضه على اتفاق سقف
الدين على ان يتم التصويت الاربعاء القادم
في الكونغرس مع وضع اللمسات الاخيره على
نصل اتفاقيه وذلك لتجنب التخلف عن سداد
الدين الحكومي قبل الخامس من يونيو وتذليل
العقبات امام التوصل الى اتفاق سيمنع
البلاد من السقوط في فخ ركود اقتصادي ونصل
اتفاقه مبدئيا مع رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي كبن مكارسي على استقرار الانفاق
غير الدفاعي للسنه الماليه الحاليه
والمقبله 20 24 كما انه لا توجد حدود قصوى
للميزانيه بعد عام 20 25 في اتفاق سقف
الدين ويجب ان يتوصل الطرفان لحل وسط بشان
تغيير قوانين فيدراليه من شانها تخفيف
اللوائح لتطوير مشاريع النفط والغاز
والطاقه المت وخطوط النقل حيث ان الاتفاق
لا يشمل اي ضرائب او برامج جديده ولكنه
يتضمن تخفيضات تاريخيه في الانفاق
تحدثت الى الرئيس مرتين بعد اسابيع من
المفاوضات توصلنا الى اتفاق من حيث المبدا
لكن لا يزال هنالك الكثير من العمل اعتقد
ان هذا الاتفاق مرضا للامريكيين يتضمن
تخفيضا تاريخيا في حجم الانفاق واصلاحات
لابعاد الناس عن الفقر ولا يكون هناك
ضرائب ولا برامج حكوميه سيتم مراجعه
الاتفاق ومناقشته مع الرئيس بايدن ومن
المتوقع التصويت على مشروع القانون
الاربعاء المقبل
منه في ولايه تكساس الامريكيه ينضم الينا
الباحث الاقتصادي والمصرفي مهند علوان
اهلا بك معنا سيد مهند اذا يعني اتفاق
مبدئي وصل اليه الطرفان بشان سقف الدين
الامريكي هل لك ان يعني توضح لنا ماذا
يشمل هذا الاتفاق ما هو تحديدا وكيف انقذ
البلاد من كارثه كما يقول الرجلان
صباح الخير فاطمه نعم تعود بنا الاحداث
الى 10 اعوام مضت عندما اجبر الجمهوريين
الرئيس اوباما على التراجع على اوباما كير
برنامج الضمان الاجتماعي عندما وافق
الطرفان على رفع سقف سقف في امريكا اليوم
تتشابه الاوضاع
الاتفاقيه جاهزه سيتم غدا تسليمها بعد
مراجعتها بشكل نهائي من قبل الرئيس رئيس
الكونجرس وتسليمها للجنه اللجنه صياغه
الدستور في الكونجرس ليتم التصويت عليها
الاربعاء
المعلومات المعلومات المبدئيه تشير بان
كلا الطرفين اتفق على حل وسط لا رابح ولا
خاسر يتضمن الحل بتحديد حجم الانفاق في
برامج معينه تتضمن برامج الفوكس الاعانه
الغذائيه برامج الانفاق المناخي
وتعهد الطرفين بعدم يعني اصدار قوانين
جديده او برامج جديده
من قبل الحكومه الامريكيه بما يلزم
الطرفين
بالتقليص الانفاق الحكومي من المتوقع ان
يتم التصويت يوم الاربعاء كلا الطرفين
متفائل بان الكونغرس سيوافق على القانون
الجديد
لتجنب اي اي تعثر حكومي
طيب سيد مهند يعني هذه الشروط ولا هذه
التنازلات التي قام بها الطرفان ربما تخيف
بعض من اعضاء الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
كيف يمكن لهما ان يتعاملان مع هذه المخاوف
تحديدا من التنازلات التي ذكرتها
عندما يوافق الطرفين في الكونجرس على
القانون الجديد كلا الطرفين قدمت تنازلات
وكلا الطرفين خرج الرئيس بايدن صرح لتويتر
ان
الطلبات المتطلبات تبعه تم الموافقه عليها
مكار في رئيس كونغرس
اعطى تصريح صحفي قال انا طلبات الجمهوريين
تم الموافقه عليها بشكل مبدئي في مسوده
سيتم طرحها غدا ليتم التصويت عليها
المخاوف موجوده ولكن
دعيني اشير ان هذه المره التسعين في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي يتم فيها
رفع السقفين بدون التعثر سواء الحديث عن
تعسر هو امر نظري صعب التطبيق اتوقع بظروف
الحاليه ولكن سوف نشاهد اثار سلبيه بغض
النظر عن كميه سقف الدين التي سيم رفعها
على اسعار الفائده ومعدلات التضخم في
الولايات المتحده وهذا سوف ينعكس على الاس
الامريكيه والعالميه خلال الاسابيع
القادمه فعلا لانه التعثر ربما يؤثر بشكل
كبير على الاسواق الماليه العالميه شكرا
جزيلا لك منه ولايه الباحث الاقتصادي
والمصرفي مهند علوان
تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي مشاهدينا تتطور
بشكل متسارع جدا الى حد انها بدات تخيف
العديد من الناس والمسؤولين من ان تسيطر
التقنيات على وظائف الناس او حتى الغاءها
فيما يعتبر او يعتبر المتحمسون للتقنيات
الجديده انها فقط البدايه لعصر جديد من
التطور الذي يقولون انه سيغير العالم بشكل
ايجابي وفعال هو شغل الشاغل للبريطانيين
وحديث الشارع الاكثر اثاره للنقاش
والحوارات المحتسبه هل تستولي تقنيات
الذكاء الاصطناعي على وظائفنا ام هل تفتح
حقبه جديده من الازدهار البشري هل مخاوف
الناس منطقيه ام انها تعيد سيناريوهات
الماضي المتخوفه دائما من التقدم
التكنولوجي
من الشركات الكبرى في العالم بدات بدمج
تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي في خدماتها
15% من الشركات البريطانيه اعتمدت شكلا من
اشكال الذكاء الاصطناعي ومن المتوقع ان
يشهد الذكاء الاصطناعي معدل النمو سنوي
باكثر من سبعه وثلاثين في المئه من عام
2023 حتى عام 2030
[موسيقى]
اما الاصوات المحذره من الذكاء الاصطناعي
فقد ازدادت في الاونه الاخيره خاصه بين
اصحاب الجيل الاكبر الذي قد يصعب عليه
التاقلم مع سرعه تقدم التقنيات الجديده
نواب بريطانيون دعو الى ضروره وضع ضوابط
على التقنيات المستخدمه خاصه مع توقعات
بنديفار 7% من جميع الوظائف خلال الخمس
سنوات المقبله
سبعه في المئه من جميع الوظائف البريطانيه
قد تخرج عن الخدمه بسبب الذك اء الاصطناعي
وبحسب احدى الدراسات يشعر
77% من الناس بالقلق من ان يتسبب الذكاء
الاصطناعي في فقدان وظائفهم فيما تشير
توقعات الدراسه الى ان تقنيات اي اي او
الذكاء الاصطناعي ستؤثر على 15% من القوه
العامله في العالم
امل ان تتحكم مع تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي
بوظائف الخدمه العملاء والوظائف التي
تتطلب التعامل مع الاشخاص والوظائف الممله
ساكون سعيدا برؤيه ذلك يحدث
لكن ليس كل ما يحيط بالذكاء الاصطناعي يعد
مثيرا للقلق متحمسون للتقنيه وجهدوا فرصه
في دمج الذكاء الاصطناعي في خدمتهم
المؤسسات التعليميه اول المستفيدين حيث
تتيح تقنيات اي اي مثلا في اخذ الطلاب في
جولات افتراضيه لحقت تاريخيه ماضيه او
التجول داخل جسم افتراضي في صف البيولوجيا
كما التقنيه الفرصه لتوفير معلم شخصي لكل
تلميذ واختبارهم قبيل الامتحانات
رغم المخاوف والحاجه الملحه لوضع ضوابط
على تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي الا انه لا
يمكن الانكار ان اي اي يتيح المزيد من
الوقت ويقلل من الجهد البشري لانجاز بعض
المهام كما قد يدفع البشر الى تطوير
مهارات قد تغير وجه العالمي للابد من لندن
عروب عبد الحق العربيه
في ختام الساعه مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور
المباشره لعمليه التصويت في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه وكما
اشرنا اقبال كبير على صناديق الاقتراب
اجراءات امنيه مشدده تنافس حاسم بين
اردوغان وكريسدر اوغلو وفي اخر التصريحات
من تركيا دعت رئيسه حزب الحزب الجيد
المعارض ميرال اكشنار دعاه الشباب التركي
الى المشاركه بكثافه في الانتخابات وكذلك
اردوغان دعاهم الى ذلك ايضا ودعاء جميع من
لم يتسنى له الفرصه للانتخاب في الجوله
الاولى ان يذهب في الجوله الثانيه وزير
الداخليه التركي سليمان سويل وقال ان
العمليه الانتخابيه تجري من دون اي مشاكل
في عموم محافظات تركيا واشار الى انه تم
نشر اكثر من 600 الفرد لتامين العمليه
الانتخابيه وعدم تسجيل اي خروج حتى اللحظه
استطلاعات الراي مشاهدينا اشارت الى ان
فجوه تصل الى 5% بين المرشحين المتنافسين
مريحه جدا لصالح اردوغان كما شاهدنا في
الجوله الاولى كذلك يعني كان اردوغان بح
سب استطلاعات الراي ايضا يعني يتفوق على
منافسه رئيس المعارضه
بشكل مريح اذا جميع الترجيحات تشير الى
ربما فوز اردوغان بخمسه نقاط على المعارضه
في الجوله الثانيه والحاسمه من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في تركيا
هذه صور مباشره ننقلها اليكم مشاهدينا
لاحد مراكز الاقتراع وغرفه غرفه غرفه
اقتراع يتواجد بها الصحفيين ربما هي بما
انها من اسطنبول ربما هي الغرفه التي
سيصوت فيها رجب طيب اردوغان للمره الثانيه
كما اشاروا مفيدين في اسطنبول بان اردوغان
من المتوقع ان يدلي بصوته ما بين الحادي
عشر الى الثاني عشر مساء
الى العناوين
جبالا والى رمز
بجوله ثانيه وحمله مليئه بالوعود بدء سباق
رئاسه التركيه اقبال لافت واجراءات امنيه
مشدده
بعد الهجمات الروسيه المكثفه كيف تدعو
سكانها الى البقاء في الملاجئ وموسكو
تستنفر على الحدود
هدنه السودان تترنح بين خروج مستمره رفعت
حصيله الضحايا وتحذيرات امميه من تفاقم
الازمه الانسانيه
اتصال الفرصه الاخيره ينقذ امريكان من
تعثر غير مسبوق بايد ومكورسي يتوصلان الى
اتفاق مبدئي حول سقف الدين
دمتم في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات